all right
okay
okay
great
welcome everybody
to another installment of our
a link gathering
today we're happy to be joined by uh
nick patricio and stuart panel here yeah
full panel thanks very much for for uh
joining guys okay look forward to
okay
look forward to hearing uh
yeah i know
we start the live feed on youtube and
then it starts up in another screen on a
delay and replays whatever we just said
okay
um
so maybe that the best thing to do and
by the way i hope everyone at home is is
um doing well and and hopefully
enjoying these gatherings gives us all a
chance to get together and talk about
language and
hopefully take our minds off maybe some
of the other things or being locked
inside or whatever is happening
um
with that maybe we'll we'll have um
uh patricio maybe you can go first
uh tell us how
a bit about yourself for sure
um and then how you use link what
languages you're studying essentially
whatever whatever you like and and then
um
we'd have a few questions after that but
we'll basically move through our three
guests and then at the end we have time
we'll have time for
for a bit of a question and answer
okay well um first of all thank you for
having me here and uh i'm patricio i'm
from mexico
i'm 19 years old and i've been using
link for about two years
um do you want me to share screen to
show you
sure
yeah sure please do that would be great
okay so
here
okay so
it depends uh on which stage i'm at so
when i'm just beginning
i try to read a lot things that are
like the basic courses
for example
link mini stories
i think you guys started more swedish
ones if i'm right
and then
how many are there now
uh 30 i think great i'll have to check
with zoran where we stand
maybe there's more on in the pipeline i
don't know
yeah well
i i start by reading a lot of uh
it it depends sometimes i change it a
little bit so
i'm gonna show you right now
it's kind of slow
by the way i'm i'm starting right now
swedish and
russian but i have learned other
languages uh on link pretty ambitious
where are you located in mexico if i may
ask
uh monterrey okay that's north right
yes
this
is one of the
biggest cities
okay it's really slow right now but so i
will show you about youtube
uh so i have i had an idea because
uh normally i watch the foreign language
videos in my
uh other youtube channel
but then
i have a lot of uh english suggestions
and spanish suggestions so if i see i
don't know a video in german that i
don't understand as well as english
i may be more tempted to watch english
videos so i normally prefer to watch uh
videos
in on this separate youtube account so
that i have more
uh
variation of languages and of course
without the distractions
so as you can see here's like russian
german russian
russian swedish so here you have all
this
um
and then if i want to search for
videos with uh
subtitles
i just
look in here
i don't know if you guys know this and
you
click like filter
and then subtitles
and you get only videos with subtitles
so then you can import easier into link
and this is
and this is across all languages so you
just go you call mexico so you want to
see a video about mexico
yes and filter subtitles so it could be
in uh
in german and italian in any well mind
you mexico that's uh some kind of uh
germanic way of spelling it
no i wrote it in in a germanic way yeah
because i want to see german videos
about mexico but if i want to see i
don't know uh
horizon traveling right
okay so i click in here and then i'll
just
filter right
subtitles right and then you'll have all
the videos with
did you subtitles
which language the subtitles are in
no uh no you you can't filter that
unfortunately but then you just
uh once during the video you can check
that but he chooses a title that's in
the the language that he's looking for
so right yeah normally and on that
subject the subtitles will presumably be
in that language
yes and then i'll just import it into
link
um
yes well let's see if it's okay so
normally i try to
uh read
all
uh trying to
see
what the words mean so i can understand
the context
and then i'll just uh
listen to it
while following it but not caring too
much about the context
about the about the meaning only about
the pronunciation and sometimes i will
listen to phrase
and then say it afterwards i think you
can hear it when i click play
so i'll just
click play and they say like
javil
and
they after awards so i can improve my
pronunciation good pronunciation by the
way pretty good thank you
uh
yeah i believe that accent is
uh about
not caring
about something sounding weird as you
said in some of your videos
plus another thing that you do that i
think is really good
is that you listen to the story you're
not too concerned about understanding
everything you just want to kind of get
some exposure to it the flow the music
of the language pick up some words
at the end of it you may only understand
60 70 percent it doesn't matter it's
just you're not too concerned and you're
starting to notice certain phrases and
certain ways words are pronounced
such a gradual process of discovery
that's good
yeah well i try to separate uh between
sometimes i'll just
try to find the meaning and sometimes
only the
the pronunciation because if i tried
both at the same time i may be confused
and it may be too much
okay
we have a question here how do you take
the subtitles and put
put them into link
uh you need to install the chrome
extension
yes so here i have the video
a little bit
so just click in here
and then well i need to move this
because it's
i click german
import
and it just takes uh it depends on your
internet
but normally it's fast open lesson so
but you don't then put it in a any
particular course you just have it's in
quick quick imports you don't set up a
course for travel or
something
and normally i don't because
uh
i'll normally import and do the lesson
uh immediately so i don't like do a
course and then i'll gonna i'm gonna do
this course and then this course so i
just
i'll normally just uh try to
wait
now it's worth pointing out again if you
can move your uh cursor up to where the
link extension icon is i think people
may have missed that that once you've
once you've downloaded the browser
extension you then have that icon and
any newspaper article
youtube video
netflix whatever you go to that same
icon
and they click on it and up pops this
dialog box and then you choose the
language you choose if you want to
import it to a specific course you can
yeah
yes
yes i like the
the link importer because if you can't
find what you want on link you can just
look at it uh somewhere else and you'll
just import it and it's great what i
like too uh
patricia what you're doing is you're
still doing a bit of the easy stuff uh
you know many stories uh who is she and
at the same time you're going into more
difficult stuff and then you go back to
easy stuff i think that's a good thing
to do is to very vary the difficulty
level yes
and i don't know if you guys have any
other questions i sometimes if i can
find uh my content i will just search uh
i'll just ask a question here so
i'm looking for a question that i asked
before
uh
you'll take a little bit again but
yes and
the good thing about having the youtube
is that
you you don't get distracted that's
something that i uh
recommend a lot
and if you're looking for a specific
content
so you just if you have any forum i
personally use the link for him you just
ask i'm looking for
uh history
things in portuguese or news or and you
say like i prefer here i said that i
prefer brazilian portuguese but i i
don't mind listening to european or
other versions
and then
people recommend a lot of uh
different uh content so
it's easy to find good content nowadays
one question patricio uh
have you
tried the uh
sort of time stamping function that
youtube sometimes offers so that if
you're going through a text and if it's
difficult and if you go through it in
sentence mode on link in fact the audio
will match that sentence
uh i i haven't tried it i normally just
do the
the whole thing
but
you mean this way like
right
okay ah
it's great if you have i have found it
doesn't always work but uh maybe mark
knows better but
in many cases uh
uh
if it's from youtube it'll be time
stamped and so that rather than this uh
audio icon being the text-to-speech
which is which is okay for one word but
it's a bit disagreeable to listen to for
a whole sentence you actually get the um
the audio from the youtube video
well okay it's great
how it actually works is we have a
a time stamp we have an ability to to
input time stamps
which means that even here in the
swedish
mini stories
when you when you when you listen to
this sentence it should be the actual
audio not text-to-speech
uh because we've actually taken the time
to input time stamps for the mini
stories
obviously it takes time to input
timestamps we have some ability to
automatically generate
timestamps now but it's a bit hit and
miss and it doesn't work in all
languages
but youtube very often
has timestamps attached to their it may
only be with the automated though um
okay uh they have automated captions
and there they a lot of the time they
have the timestamps
uh as well
with the manual translations unless the
unless the uh
owner has put the timestamps in it may
not work it it but if the command
are present we can import the timestamps
but they're not always present that's
the
first of all to repeat then any our
content like who is she or the many
stories in many cases we have the times
we manually put the timestamps in
insofar as the automatic timestamps from
youtube i have found it pretty good for
turkish and there was even a video in
levantine arabic and they had
standard arabic subtitles and they came
in time stamped and those are put in
manually because the woman is speaking
levantine i suspect that a lot of
youtube videos will have time stamps and
if they have timestamps then we'll have
them too okay
yeah
uh and and
that's really for all users if you want
to want that functionality to work for
whatever lesson you happen to be
studying you can manually put in the
timestamps actually
may take a bit of time but it does
depending on the length of the lesson it
can be worth doing because then you do
get to listen to that
sentence
uh the actual audio for that sentence
um okay well patricio that was that was
great
uh
yeah i mean i
definitely helps me
learn how to use youtube better and uh
i know we had some good suggestions in
previous uh gatherings also on on using
uh
youtube so
somehow we need to gather all this
information in one place because it is
great to
learn from people who have figured out
the different ways of doing it okay uh
nick maybe you can go next
introduce yourself and and uh yeah
let us all use you use link
sure uh so thanks for having me on
everyone my name is nick i'm from uh
kansas here in the united states of
america
and uh i've been learning japanese for
about three years now maybe a little
over three years and about half of that
time with link so uh before i used link
you know i didn't really know how to go
about language learning
my only experience had been a couple
years of spanish in a school which i you
know didn't really do too well in
but uh with japanese you know i started
using like some phrase books and some
courses and such um which were you know
pretty good for the beginner stuff but
i kept running into this problem of
never really getting beyond the beginner
level uh and switching you know between
different courses but each one would run
out of material um unfortunately i came
across your guys's videos you know a lot
of steve's videos on uh how he uses link
the reading and listening
a lot of the um
you know finding stuff you're interested
in and using native materials so i i
signed up for link started using it and
uh at first i really was just reading
lots of short stories you know like who
is she and nhk easy news and stuff
and uh i tried to kind of increase how
much i did each month so like at first
it was maybe just 200 words a day i
would read and then bumped it up to 500
and eventually a thousand um
and yeah you know i use blink very
similar to how patricia showed i
basically would just uh read the page
down linking any new words and stuff and
then
listen to the audio
so that i could kind of hear what i just
read since a lot of times like the way
uh native will say something can kind of
hint at a different understanding of
what i had the first time
um and yeah after maybe six months of
using link i decided to finally try and
read my first like full-length novel
there's a couple books on link
and it was tough
um i think it took me over a month to do
because uh even
having used link for a while there were
still just thousands of words i didn't
know and uh
i think you know after i finished
reading it
uh i maybe only understood 60 of the
whole story but it just felt like such
an accomplishment because every time i
had tried to read you know like a
physical book it was just impossible
they would take so long to look up the
new words and try and write them down so
i could remember it
um and yeah so that was pretty
incredible to be able to use link and
accomplish something like that for
myself
uh but yeah you know i basically just
get on and nowadays i'll import use your
import feature to put in books and audio
books that i find and enjoy
and just read through them and it's
really interesting because instead of
like trying to learn the language i'm
really just trying to enjoy the story
and i just kind of happen to you know
pick up new words as i go through it
uh and it's really yeah i've never found
any other course or anything that
helps you learn this way
so yeah that's pretty much my experience
with it
just like to make one comment first of
all you are the absolute model link user
that's
exactly the idea
yeah that i have that many people have
and that is that we just enjoy exploring
things in the language not
we're not deliberately trying to learn
the language the language is just coming
in as we explore these other things
another thing i've said before is when
you read your first novel in the
language you're learning that is a major
milestone that's the mountain you have
climbed and everyone should do that
because as you say understand 60 70 it
doesn't matter you have such a
tremendous sense of achievement
and every time we have a sense of
achievement the brain gets this dopamine
kick like look at me i climbed the
mountain i read a book now you know i'm
ready for anything so yeah you're uh
right on that's that's the way to go
about it one thing one other thing i
would add
is when we read and both you and
patricio you read a lot
but i find that that's very important to
listen because when we're reading in a
foreign language we're always
sub-vocalizing obviously if you're
reading your native language it's
instant meaning you don't necessarily
sub-vocalize but when you're reading in
a foreign language you tend to
sub-vocalize and so the better you
pronounce the more you have listened
the listening gives you some momentum so
that when you are reading and
sub-vocalizing you're actually getting
closer to the way the language is
pronounced you're getting closer to the
intonation which is also so very
important
so listening to me is a big part of
reading you can't separate you can't
just read without listening i think the
two of them reinforce each other the
reading helps us remember the words but
the listening gives us that that sense
of the the music the rhythm of the
language that that helps us when we read
so
yeah great
i mean uh
the the reading books is the
major driver for vocabulary girls too he
just gets so many words
i don't know of any other way to get
that volume of words uh really
videos are great and they are enjoyable
but they're just not as word dense
so uh
yeah definitely something
everyone should consider mixing into
their
link mix is is his books for sure
um
great i don't know if there were any
questions that we should be looking at
here i think there's one in the mark
where do you find japanese books and
audio books and i know you also have
been looking for you might want to deal
write that question
no yeah japanese books and audio but
where do you find
them uh so yeah so
they're pretty hard to find i don't know
if there's something with the japanese
you know digital laws but i've i have
found a couple on amazon
there's a lot of public domain books on
like uh
some websites
um
that you can search for and find
what i have done is there's actually a
good number of books just on link kind
of in the library you can search and
find them in there that's where i found
my first couple ones
okay
yeah
yeah we should uh maybe we'll put
together some kind of uh maybe even on
the forum as patricio suggested get a
forum going on on uh link books and try
to put whatever resources we can find in
there and gradually figure out
uh that to how we can help people get
get books and for whatever reason as you
say
japanese seems to be they have different
formats and and
hard to remove
not as
as available not as much information on
how to
get them into a format that can be
accessible
um
okay
so then why don't we move on then maybe
we'll move on to stuart and thanks very
much nick that was that was great
uh how about how about you stuart all
right sounds good hey guys thanks for uh
inviting me in and um
i i'll uh go ahead and share my screen
i kind of formatted this for my thinking
here
what we got here okay
so uh just a bit of background i teach
english
i've been doing it for five years and
the main thing i've noticed with the
best students
that i've ever had where they were
spending a lot of time binge watching tv
especially friends
uh reading a lot of books
a lot of social media posts like reddit
facebook
or they were forced to use the language
by being an exchange student or moving
to a new country or working with
foreigners especially coders
um dating but
and from my experience i'm living in
brazil right now so i have to learn
portuguese in this case because
you'll just find a lot of people don't
speak english here um
and people who create kind of these
language zones and
ones who come to my lessons prepared
with questions from their own self-study
and that's kind of really what i want to
get into
was just like my mistakes and challenges
where i was also i was always focusing
kind of like finding the perfect program
and or the perfect method and i realized
through watching a lot of uh steve's
videos
there is no such thing you really gotta
use the tools
a variety of tools
and
i was also struggling finding
transcripts because i really wanted to
find podcasts but most of them don't
have transcripts
um
same thing with videos although with
what patricio talked about earlier uh i
discovered the same thing very recently
super helpful and that kind of broke
open my
life uh just kind of my frustration was
studying recently so
along with the forum i would have to say
link q's community is super inspiring
like i came across this guy here uh
i think his name is herb or herb and he
just kind of created a six month
practice schedule and he just basically
explained like every single method he's
going to use and three hours a day if
you can have the time one hour a day and
i thought well i have one to three hours
a day
and
i've been focusing too much on just one
method or one source of material and
really the key is
make a do a variety of things i don't
know why that never really stuck in my
mind as ringing true but
after really following herb there it
inspired me to just kind of walk in his
footsteps a bit and
especially the mechanical goals i know
steve you've talked a lot about
mechanical goals and that's helped a lot
with me just
you know at first seeing a 50 word a day
thing
um
that's one goal i can have like but i
also
i struggled with finding
being able to kind of study anywhere
anytime so i realized i don't just have
to study in front of my computer it can
be through my phone through listening
material thankfully a link link includes
audio from the mini stories or i've
managed to find uh
you know sources for uh old glossika
books audio files or penciller so
they're not the they're not going to
make you fluent but just if i'm able to
study anytime anywhere that's my goal
now
uh youtube as as patricia talked about
youtube is uh the go-to now i remember
uh what was her name clara from
the meetup number two she mentioned uh
zero to hero i went there immediately
when i watched that video but
unfortunately portuguese
it just pops up korean and english and
stuff so i realized okay this isn't my
solution
uh but the website does give
instructions for how to find those
which is what patricio mentioned
and just like patricio in the target
language i'll search for cartoons and
portuguese casinos animals
or if you want to get um
really more specific you can put in the
uh
the channel i'm sorry what you're
looking for
with um
the country so design your sunday mottos
brazil
and
yes it's not perfect every time but
within the first top three or four
videos you'll find
videos with the correct transcripts so
you know
brazilian portuguese is unique from
portugal now some of these are
portuguese in
brackets brazil
and usually if you find one that channel
has a bunch of uh videos with
transcripts provided and if you
if not everyone does then you can just
type in the channel name again with the
uh
with you know subtitles cc clicked
checked and you will definitely find all
the videos they do have
with the subtitles of your choice import
it like you mentioned
um
i'd also strongly recommend this channel
for all people in the lo in the beginner
stages this stephen maggie he's got
basically a channel for
almost every language every major
european
with uh but they're all
i mean i know a lot of vocabulary just
by being married to brazilian but like
my sentence director is pretty bad but
if i i'm not afraid to go back to basics
with with steve and maggie's stuff
um so do that anyway um
and then
uh yeah what else should i mention here
um
video speed matthew from live gathering
three
he mentioned a good way of studying
spanish by not just slowing it down but
also speeding it up past 100 percent and
if someone's speaking language too fast
um
just go faster and then slow it back
down and ta-da it sounds like uh it's
slow to you now so i've taken that to
heart
um
i'll also mention that ocr technology
has been pretty pretty cool so i like to
uh i'll give an example here
if i can i'll full screen this more
i like to find signs around my building
and i'm like what the heck does this say
i'll take a picture of it you know on my
phone
go into the google app and port it uh or
take a picture through the app
just do an automatic scan
import the portuguese and i'll throw it
right into my link account here
and then uh i got a bunch of new links
for the day to go through
so strongly recommend that if
if um if you have pdfs i you
know
yeah
and now i can know what the sign says um
i also say i through the
i can't figure out how to do this with
jpeg images on
google translate on your computer but
it's easy to do through your phone on
the computer you can import pdfs docs
um i actually have a
let me share a new screen here another
program called pdf exchange so i have
like a glossa document right here so
any
sentences i want to work through um now
i as you can as i'll just try to
demonstrate
for whatever reason i can't highlight
but this pdf viewer comes with an ocr
scanner i can just put in the page which
is uh 95 according to the digital file
it'll scan it
and now i can now i can copy these
sentences right into link you and create
a new lesson for myself so i i really
just want to
get everything i am interacting with
into link
and not lose any of it because i it's
really
yeah it's really encouraging to see that
new words counting up up and up and up
and getting more links
um so
that's one thing i really wanted to
mention uh
on this broadcast here
and then
other than that i know there's probably
a lot of people who have books and they
can't find an e-book version they're
just too old
i don't think it's been mentioned in any
of the gatherings but there are websites
like
blueleafscanning.com
and one dollar scan basically you can
send a book to them you can send it
right from amazon.com even
one of them says that they will return
the book to you they won't cut it up but
both of them their cheaper price is to
cut up the book scan it but then they'll
send you a
file and you can read that on your
computer one
even we'll give you an audiobook version
of it of course it's just using text to
uh text-to-speech
but i've heard one of them it was as a
sample it was pretty good um but it's
just an added bonus you get from it
but i know for me i got a bunch of
portuguese books that have no ebooks
that where i just can't find them so i
might be interested in using that
service
um
and
also amazon kindle
i've used to search
through amazon.com us
but i discovered if i go to the country
of focus in this case um
brazil although
i'm afraid i might not have
saved it here okay well if you go to
oh yeah here i got my links so that
makes it easy for me
that i prepared that so if you go to the
amazon brazil in my case uh
i'm
again i'm kind of interested in building
up my my basic science structure so i'm
more interested in looking kind of
graded readers from the start and
amazon as you know is a very organized
company so but i just found that going
to the brazilian amazon provided more
options than what i can find on the
american site
so that's just the tip i just like to
include there was materials i couldn't
even find as a
like sometimes i would just experiment a
search ward on regular amazon.com it was
there but sometimes it wasn't there as a
kindle option i don't know why
so i would suggest make an account in
the country where the link
whatever language you're using and
especially if you're more interested in
say mexico spanish maybe go to amazon
mexico search for it there
and
then
sort of interrupt one thing there i know
that at least in japan
amazon doesn't actually let you buy
books which seems strange but
okay you need an address in japan i
don't know how it is in brazil but or
amazon brazil but i i did i have
experienced things like that in brazil
as far as they want to have like a local
credit card and stuff right um
i
i'll be honest i don't know if i use my
wife's credit card for that but yeah
that could happen that could that that
kind of issue could pop up
uh there are a lot of free amazon kindle
books so they might let you get away
with it if you get one of the free
downloads
um but yeah good note
um
i just kind of like a little tool that
if anyone's interested it's like a
really weak version of link but just
relaying it i i use it just for websites
where it's just like menus
uh of like this
i don't know i just got i can highlight
certain words and it pops up i i just
thought people might be interested in
that um
but
for the most part anything i'm reading
i'm important to link you to keep track
of my keep track of my links
um
and then
yeah oh yeah i like to copy and paste
things from facebook messages text
messages
uh facebook groups i've really gotten to
try to get into facebook groups kind of
seeing how brazilians communicate with
each other making lessons out of that
because again i mentioned i had a
student he was his main reading material
was facebook groups and reddit and he
just
his english sounded amazingly natural
and he he just moved to the u.s i think
when he was 20 and he was 21 by the time
i talked to him and he was a bit of a
introvert
so
from what i could gather he built a lot
of the skill up through that just by
kind of
more natural english exchange through
online forums
and i want to mention tags the tags mark
you mentioned tags in a gathering and i
found after you mention those i found
those really useful for myself because
sometimes i i guess at the beginning i
felt like i'm linking a lot of stuff and
then
i want to see it again and i might
forget the word
or the words but if i just create my own
tags
especially with like why i'm confused by
like grammar question or
you know insults i can just pop those
right up and
get them get them focused on i'm not too
worried about srs i mean i can show you
like i'm kind of am focused on anytime
anywhere
so if i don't have something i'm
interested in listening to if i'm just
in a car and i just want to
um flip through stuff i did find
interesting and something i read i do
throw this into a srs flash card app i
have i don't use anki yankees just not
my style but um i do appreciate the
text-to-speech
um technology that's come along i'll
come a long way for these flashcard apps
um and then i could just i don't know i
i i feel like i don't need to memorize
or perfect anything it's just constant
exposure to things i've seen in the past
and it's good enough for me for and it's
been a lot i've been able to focus a lot
more on studying um consistently now
with uh with all of that and not just
not trying to perfect anything
but uh but yeah that's all i have to
present here today
yeah can i make a comment and ask a
question uh sure okay so first of all
the comment is i think one thing that a
lot of people don't realize is the
importance of variety
and what you presented is a very good
example of variety
and i think a lot of people in
traditional language
situ learning situations especially in
the in
asian countries they're going to try and
nail something down they stay with it
they just pound it try and pound it into
their head you know lists of words
grammar rules i remember doing that
myself the same
german declension table i looked at for
the umpteenth time and of course we
don't learn that way we can't force it
that we're learning less and less every
time we're retaining less and less every
time we deliberately try to do that so
if we can you know have some easy some
difficult some flash cards someday it's
them that the greater the variety the
brain likes that the brain likes to
explore new things so i think you're on
the right track there but i had a
question too
uh you mentioned amazon can you get
amazon books interlink kindle books
interlink
um boy it's been a little while since i
did it but i think what i was doing was
i might have been cheating with my um
my google translate ocr technology so if
i i can i can take a picture of the
screen
and pour it into my phone and then use
that ocr
uh it's a little slow and tedious but um
i might have had a quicker method i
can't remember exactly yeah
it and i think you know
they kind of change their
drm
sometimes but i think i'm trying to
remember the last time i tried to to
import a kindle book uh first of all you
can search google and
the biggest issue is um
actually i'm trying to remember now so
there used to be a kit there is a kindle
desktop app yeah
so if you have the kindle desktop app
you can download the kindle book to your
computer
and then you have to find the file on
your computer and once you have the file
then you have to figure out how to
remove the drm but amazon is making it
more difficult now to find the file on
your computer which is
uh i think one of the issues
um i can't i haven't actually done it
lately
but at least before it was yeah not that
difficult if you you once you figure out
where they store the file on your
computer you find that file
i think caliber had a head
used to be able to a plug-in that would
uh remove the drm
and then you could convert it to
whatever file type you needed and import
it into link but i think kindle is
making it tougher which is too bad like
i've bought the book why can't i read it
where i want to read it um but
you know we'll um
spend a bit of time there and try and
figure out
a good way of doing that i mean i guess
we probably shouldn't be promoting
removing drm i don't know if that's
illegal or not being honest but
i had another question for stewart yeah
i kind of missed the part where you took
a picture of those whatever it was in
your
apartment building and suddenly that
became a lesson at link like what what
soft okay so i go and take a picture of
something then what happened
okay uh i'll open that right now so
i
take a picture with
if i could show my phone of course i can
but you have the google translate app on
your phone there is a camera button
that you should see in there
and
when you open that
yeah okay
um you can watch the recording of this
later yeah
and then you can click this scan button
which you'll see right there if i
yeah you see that there okay and after
you press scan it it scans everything
everything is
actually you can click uh it'll ask you
what do you want to scan you click
select all that's what i do yeah and
then it sends that right into this box
it'll show you the the native language
and the translated english i just copy
and paste with my finger
um
and then i i email that to myself
yeah so you send it to google translate
so you're very clever very very clever
so you're using google translate but but
i'm i am keeping the original language
it is keeping the original portuguese so
yeah yeah exactly it's just it's just a
means you're utilizing that
functionality of google translate in
order to get the thing into
into a format where you can import it
into link exactly i actually thank you
i i've done this before uh and i this is
is this uh is this an android uh phone
that is an android yeah um i haven't
experimented with that iphone though
okay i've done it on my iphone and i i
believe i i somehow stumbled upon the
ability to select all or copy all or
something there is a way
it's i will say it's a little confusing
at first because there will be uh it
at first it just starts automatically
translating it and it's a bunch of
floating words
um yeah so you definitely want to click
that scan button
yeah
but
it worked pretty well i've done that too
it's it uh it's kind of it's a neat neat
functionality for sure yeah it's helped
a lot yeah
like a question for you guys and one of
the things i mean we're always looking
at how we can do things better um
i sometimes find myself wishing i was
able to email into my link account
how many how many of you
listening at home or or in this call
would be interested in that
functionality could you explain what you
mean
like if i either i get an email in
japanese so now i i
rather than having to copy and paste
that text and create a lesson if i could
just if i had a
unique email address on link that i
could just forward that email to
and then it would just create it for me
and and and likewise here you know if
you you're saying you email that to
yourself and then you can probably copy
and paste it into link well if you email
it to your mailbox link uh i i do i do
get uh emails from brazilian companies
like my phone company or cable company
and i am always sending those over to
link so so mark you would have an email
address like link at
like steve steve link at link dot or
whatever you know yeah lingo steve at
link oh okay whatever and you just
forward it everything you want to import
to your own account you forward it there
and it'll just
open up as a lesson lesson yeah i like
that idea that'd be cool good that would
be good yeah that'd be really cool
yeah okay mark should be i see
i see a couple of questions here from
amanda
who uh
so
one of them was what are your thoughts
of just having the playlist playing in
the background as you're working
that is my major learning activity i go
to a course i hit play course audio
so i don't have to you know make a
playlist every time because it's i find
that too time-consuming whereas
typically the average course has 10 15
or more uh lessons in it play course
audio
and then i can start at less than one or
i can start at less than 10 and then i
make breakfast so during the day if i'll
get in 45 minutes to an hour every day
most of the time i'm listening to
listen to course audio which in a way is
playlist but it's just easier to get at
i don't have to make the playlist i if
i used to have different things in my
playlist from different courses now i
don't if i get tired of that course i go
to another course play course audio and
away i go so that that's the answer to
one of your questions having said that
can i just chime in i don't do that i
never listen to her wrong i never listen
to courses i have a i i it takes no time
to create a playlist because your
playlist is created automatically every
time you complete a lesson that lesson
is added to your playlist
if you want to you can go to your
playlist and remove the lessons you're
no longer interested in
but i tend to just
leave it and then whatever plays plays
and and i it's
it's actually the
most easy way to listen
um
whenever i go do anything i just start
my playlist on my
on my iphone on my home screen i tap on
the link button which gives a
quick pop-up menu i tap playlist and i'm
listening it's super fast and it just
plays a random
assortment of whatever i've been
studying for the last six months which
is good so you get some easy stuff you
get some more difficult stuff and you
don't really know what's coming at you
sometimes if i've just done a lesson
then i'll listen to that lesson and set
it to repeat but i i i never do the
course thing largely because i don't
study whole courses at a time i think
like i i kind of just kind of jump from
here to there and import some stuff and
obviously the imported stuff's not in
your playlist because there's no audio
but
all the stuff from the from our library
is is in there and
that's how i do it so i think
whatever works for you
although that's uh that's wrong
no we rarely agree mostly i'm right
um not so not so by the way no so anyway
that's super convenient uh you were
saying there's another question there
uh you're amused there was one other
what oh what is the flash card app i
don't know what that question refers to
maybe i mentioned
i think i mentioned i was uh using a
flash flashcard app i i i
i didn't say specifically i use
flashcards deluxe
um it's just a little bit simpler than
anki and like i said i use it actually
mostly for the
uh
the text-to-speech option in it you can
import like amazon voice into it and it
just automatically has a nice amazon
brazilian portuguese woman or man's
voice and it just automatically reads
through it and it's a good way to
to review stuff
uh someone here asking which do you
think is better for immersion early on
watching things you've already seen in a
language you understand or watching
something you haven't
i don't understand the question because
if it's early on
then
how is that a language you understand i
i think if you've watched the show in
your own language or in in a language
that you oh
so that you've seen it before
um in a language you understand i guess
okay well i mean i would say that
obviously
the more familiar you are with any
subject
book
tv program whatever the easier it is to
understand
so
if you're struggling and you're learning
a new language and you can see something
where you are kind of familiar like i
find this myself when i'm doing the mini
stories because i know the many story i
know the menu story in greek and
romanian so if i listen to the mini
story in arabic and now i'm listening to
the mini story which i've listened to in
standard arabic i'm listening to it in
love and arabic so the more familiar the
thing is that just it just makes it that
much easier to connect with the meaning
so um
to the extent that it but the bigger
issue is how interested are you so if
you're interested in something that
you're not so familiar with go for that
on the other hand it can be
useful to watch something in the
language you're learning where you
already know the story
um well
okay great we have we have some
questions from youtube as well
um
as i start to acquire vocabulary find it
easier to do it through reading alone is
that okay for the initial accumulation
of vocabulary
well i mean from my perspective reading
alone like any time i have dedicated
time i read
and i find sometimes
you know i'll listen and read at the
same time especially in say arabic or
persian because it's so difficult to get
used to another script sophie here asks
how do you get used to reading in a
different alphabet there is no shortcut
you just have to read lots and so
sometimes because i'm tired of not
getting the pronunciation of the word in
persian or arabic i'll listen as i read
however when i just read i have the
feeling that i'm it's better for me it's
just that i'm lazy and so i prefer to
have the sound to help me along
but
if i in fact
force myself to read i think i'm really
training my mind to read
so i think reading alone is good for you
but it gets back to what i said about
stuart too is variety is good
and i think i think they're they're
asking as well like
with regard to to uh
acquiring vocabulary through reading
alone i have to say that i
i almost
never do
review dedicated review like flash card
review or using our activities on link
and
uh and that's not to say that
they're not helpful but i i don't do it
at all i just acquire vocabulary through
reading as you're
you're asking and and um
it works i mean
you know and it's it's uh slower
progress in in japanese just because
you know compared to say italian where
there are so many similar words to to
english uh but uh it's it's
you your your vocabulary just just grows
because in fact you are reviewing every
time you come across a word in a new
context and you click on it oh yeah
that's what that is and then by you know
the seventh or eighth time you see it
somewhere else
yeah you've seen it enough times and and
gradually you start to realize that a
lot of the yellow words on the page you
actually know and can start moving them
to known and and uh
i i i don't i still believe that there's
no faster way to grow your vocabulary
than by doing it that way because you
cannot possibly
flash card enough words it just takes
too long it's not efficient enough and
at the same time when you're reading
you're getting that all of that ex that
that reinforcement from the listening
and from the reading of the patterns of
the language and
and um yeah i think
if if you if i had to choose
uh
to do one to learn vocabulary through
flashcards or through reading
there wouldn't be much of a choice for
me
one other thing is i find that in a
language early on in the language
um
the audio
that i would listen to is faster than i
can read
however if the if the language is
written in the latin alphabet very
quickly i can read faster than the audio
and so as soon as i can read faster than
the audio i no longer want to listen to
the audio i'm just going to read because
i can go faster now if you're in a
writing system that's different
like arabic and persian for me
there is no way that i can read faster
than the audio because it's such a
struggle so like that's where i rely on
this crutch of listening but i think
here again you have to vary it and i
think one way of increasing your reading
speed if you're at a stage where the
audio is faster than you can read
then to try and read along at the same
speed as the audio that's going to help
you speed up your reading
uh so i think it's just a matter of
playing with those two things you have
the option and and doing it you know
sentence by sentence and then trying to
stay with it trying to keep up the audio
speed and trying to get to where you
match the audio speed and eventually to
where you can read faster than the audio
speed
no question and we have someone asking
how did you cope with the three writing
systems in japanese
obviously reading in japanese
way better very helpful to to to have
the audio
uh playing at the same time
um yeah the three running since
obviously
i mean you're referring to hiragana
katakana and kanji
um
you have to start but by learning the
hiragana and then the katakana i mean
you have to learn that too and they're
they're not that difficult to learn i
mean they're
phonetic that there's i don't know how
many 30 of each
um and then the kanji
i actually i did a book called
remembering the kanji which had you
trying to which use
[Music]
mnemonics whatever however you say that
to um try and remember them i did that
actually for a while
but you don't learn
the pronunciations of the characters i i
don't think
it was actually that efficient a use of
time to be honest um i would have been
better off i think
um
you know just focusing on trying to
learn this a smaller number
and then starting to read i think
starting to read
the power of seeing those kanji the most
common kanji you see them all the time
all the time all the time you gradually
start to learn them
uh a little bit of time up front
identifying the different types of
shapes and the characters is good to
kind of get your brain steve steve
always talks about the ability to notice
notice that there are different elements
in the characters that do tie together
and have similar pronunciations um
and then just just kind of forging ahead
and seeing them and i don't know i guess
that's how i've done it and i i mean i
can
i can make my way through a simple
japanese
and not an insignificant number of of
kanji that i can read when i'm reading
and so that's at least for me steve
maybe you could jump oh let's just uh uh
increase your reading speed in languages
with different alphabet you know i often
quote manfred spitzer and his book you
know
and he says that the brain is a
pattern
extraction machine so the brain will
start to pick up on things but he also
says the brain learns slowly and i found
with reading in writing systems other
than the latin alphabet
even if you know it like i i my russian
is much better than my check it's much
easier for me to read czech than russian
even though the cyrillic alphabet is not
particularly difficult but
you know you've spent your whole life
reading in the latin alphabet
so you've got all of that experience
your brain has all that exposure to the
latin alphabet now you hit it with a
brand new alphabet
no matter how much you work at it it's
going to be slower and the only solution
the advice is read more
that's it that's all and slowly the
brain is going to start getting used to
it
uh someone asked steve your book written
in 2003 the way of the linguist was a
great read do you intend to write
another book or have you
[Laughter]
you know i should in a way
it was a lot of work i mean it's not a
very big book it's like whatever it is
150 pages
it's a lot of work because you're
forever rewriting whatever you're that's
the first time i've ever you know had
ever written a book so you write it you
rewrite it you don't like this you don't
like that
but um yeah i kind of think i should
because it's amazing 2003 here we are
2020 a lot has changed a lot has changed
in terms of technology in terms of the
world in terms of everything that's you
know the polyglot community and the
number of people who are learning or
teaching online and of course
link has evolved it maybe i should
maybe i will
[Laughter]
okay
um
hi steve mark and guess my question is
can we talk about being fluent in
speaking
language or can we also talk about
fluency in reading and writing so do we
only talk about fluency in terms of
speaking or are we talking about it in
terms of reading and writing
oh he seemed to be on mute
i think if we look at the way the word
is used most people take fluency to mean
the ability to speak
speak and to understand so you can get
in a situation you're talking to someone
you understand what they're saying they
understand what you're saying it doesn't
mean you're perfect
but you can function you know if you go
to mongolia to do business you sit down
over a cup of tea or whatever they do
there and you're operating that's fluent
uh
yeah the ability to read to read
you know
complicated books all of that is fine
but if you cannot
converse with people and understand with
what people are saying then i think
the common definition says that you're
not fluent
uh do you think reading in the beginning
stages can be dangerous because you can
accidentally learn incorrect
pronunciation
i don't think anything you do at the
beginning can be dangerous
because you're going to be exposed to so
much
listening reading whatever and stuff
like
you you're going to pronounce very
poorly at the beginning if you get
surrounded by more of the language you
will your pronunciation will evolve i
don't think anything you do at the
beginning can be dangerous no that's my
opinion
and obviously at the beginning stages
one other thing that that's super
important which you say all the time is
you should be doing a lot of listening
at the beginner stages so that well
exactly train your brain as to how
things should sound and hope they start
to make those sounds when you speak
i mean typically when i start up say
arabic or persian i'm listening i don't
understand a thing it's just noise
lesson one of the many stories just
noise and i say to myself how will i
ever
understand this language and then i go
and try and read it and it's all these
little squigglies like how will i ever
ever overcome this and with time you do
but listening is is 75 of my of my
the time that i spent
and i have to say that you know i get we
get questions obviously all the time and
and uh you know there's an automated
email that goes out from me to everybody
who joins link asking you know how they
find it and so on and um
you know a lot of people will come back
and and and say you know i'm having
trouble i it's a lot of people if they
start on the mini stories uh it's i
don't understand i need i need uh
you know i guess they're probably used
to duolingo so they'll get like dog and
cat and and uh
mama whatever they get teach there and
and and they feel like
they need that because it's too
overwhelming to get this
wall of text and audio at the beginning
and even though it is actually simple
content and it's not that much it does
feel that way and can't feel that way
when you start and the
part of the problem is that everybody's
can kind of condition to feel like i
need to understand this and be able to
make sense of it right now and i think
that's your point steve is that no you
don't you absolutely do not just let
just read it try and listen try and
follow along do follow along do your
best
and and do that and make your links and
move on to the next lesson and when
you've kind of
had enough of this one and
and then check back in a month and and
go back to that first lesson that you
started on and you'll be amazed at how
much of it now makes sense
how much better your listening
comprehension is your ability to work
your way through it this idea that
you don't don't expect perfection up
front don't worry about it just let the
your brain will sort it out
i'd like to ask nick and patricio
your experience
i find that a brand new language and
i've done it now for greek for turkish
persian arabic difficult languages i get
on there
my mini story one
kind of i understand 20 i move on to
mini story two three four five go back
to one and that's the process and and
for a long long time it's all foggy is
that the way you go at it when you start
from scratch like uh patricia with the
swedish or nick i guess you already had
your japanese going into it but
have you found that you're prepared to
move forward even though you don't
understand it or do you tend to want to
nail down a lesson before moving on
well i normally try to read everything
like the first lesson about three times
and then i i go to the next one and to
the next one and eventually i'll come
back
and then do it again and then come back
and do it again
and at the beginning it feels like you
don't understand anything
uh it is
kind of weird that i have the same
feeling that you
said you had that it's like
how can i
understand this language like i right
now i don't understand anything how will
i achieve to do it it just
it seems uh
that it
it will never happen but then the months
pass by and all of a sudden you think
like oh my gosh i'm reading this
in in
russian and i forgot that it was russian
or i'm reading this in german and i
completely forgot that it was german
so that's the point where you
where you
start to feel more motivation
and other things that help me
plow through those stages are
watching my stats that helped me a lot
and also taking
pictures every time that i that i i
don't know yesterday i achieved
5 000 words in russian and i always take
a picture picture picture so when i see
it in my phone i remember like oh my
gosh i remember
when i knew 2 000 words and i was
excited and now i know 5 000 so
it keeps me going it's a good idea yeah
that's great
kind of saves it in your photo timeline
that's kind of interesting
um it's also
yeah it's great yeah
it's kind of neat to go to your uh
profile and look at your
all-time stats
graphs too i find that
motivating so you can see over time how
your known words have grown
anyway nick yeah please go ahead oh yeah
sure um you know i don't uh
i don't like to get stuck on something
that i don't understand and i know that
uh i can always come back to it later so
normally yeah i try my best um if
there's a word or a phrase i just can't
figure out i just you know just move on
um
because
to me you know making that progress
getting through the book is more
important than you know understanding it
100
and you know steve talks a lot on his
videos about variety mixing it up both
in content and difficulty and so after a
couple months or so of reading different
things um when i would go back and
reread an old book or an old lesson or
something from like six months before i
would find it uh i understand it way
better and i might even notice some
things that i misunderstood the first
time
but i feel like if i had just
gotten stuck on it i wouldn't have made
all that progress so i just you know
take what i can and just let the cards
fall where they may
you know it's interesting about going
over material
so i've been i've left my turkish uh you
know because i want to focus on the
arabic writing system so i'm doing
persian and arabic and then i get a
little bit afraid that i'm losing my
turkish so i go and pick up i have a
book like teach yourself or whatever it
is turkish book and i start going
through it and of course i've forgotten
a bunch of stuff
but
it suddenly struck me that you know how
you have that feeling if you're going
somewhere for the first time whether
you're walking or going by car
it seems like a long way
like it took us a long time to get there
but the second time you go there
it doesn't seem like was that that it
was that far at all like you're there in
no time and i have that same feeling
when i review my turkish now that i
haven't looked at for months
yeah there's words i've forgotten but
like i have the feeling that it's
sticking better like like i'm walking
through that a lot faster now because
i've been down that road before
so there's no great danger in leaving
something and then coming back to it
and in fact there's research
this robert bjork out of ucla who shows
that when we forget something and go
back and relearn it we learn it better
so
yeah and that apparently is how the
brain works it all gets back this idea
don't try and sock something in you know
stay with it until you've got it nailed
down go off wander off somewhere else
and then come back to it and learn it
again you'll learn it faster and you're
going to sock it in to the rain better
so uh with that in mind i don't worry
about stuff that i don't like all of you
are saying that i don't understand
whatever i just move on i go back again
i move on and every time i'm coming back
there and i'm going over the same ground
again i'm learning it better
and and there's you know neurological
research and and if you want to look up
robert bjork on youtube
he talks a lot about interleaving so and
i would say too that if you're you know
don't understand a word or don't
understand a phrase
i always say
if it matters you'll see it again or
you'll see a similar phrase or you'll
see the same phrase written slightly
differently and in different contexts
and
over time if if if those words or
phrases matter you'll see them again and
and you'll learn them
you don't need to learn them the first
time
yeah
um let's see what else we have on uh
were there more questions in that um
a zoom
chat box
i guess we have another one here related
to kanji if i learned kanji in japanese
uh
will it be the same for chinese
only just changing the pronunciation
well as as someone who's done both
chinese and japanese they're very
similar so between traditional chinese
characters simplified chinese characters
japanese characters a lot of japanese
characters are similar to traditional
some are some are some have their own
simplification it's basically variations
on the same theme so it's very very
helpful of course you move into a new
language there's new things new
pronunciation
slightly different forms of certain
characters but it's it's tremendously
helpful whether you're going from
japanese into chinese or from chinese
into japanese having that characters is
tremendously helpful
uh we have a steve could you talk a bit
about
the beginnings of link and the
the that entrepreneur start
calling it an entrepreneur start is uh
not that accurate
uh
so i have all i i've said this before
like i i have lots of books at home in
spanish in german in different languages
and i would read them and on every page
there's 10 words that i don't know or 15
or however many and so you underline
them or you write them out in a list and
then you go look them up and you never
look at the list again you forgot what
whatever the meanings were so there's
still the same 10 words you don't know
in every page in the language that
continues spanish german doesn't matter
so that always stuck with me and and
when i was learning languages like
chinese and that i would and for german
as well i would scour bookstores for for
readers that had word lists behind each
you know chapter
but that wasn't very satisfactory either
because very often the word that you
needed to know wasn't on the word list
and half the word list consisted of
words that you knew
so you say i don't know this word you go
to the word it's not there but there's a
whole bunch of other words that for you
these are easy why have they got these
words on the word list you know so it's
just all very unsatisfactory so
with and then the other thing of course
was that when i was learning you know 50
years ago a tape recorder was a great
big open real tape recorder which didn't
go anywhere although there were these
ghetto blasters
i remember people used to walk around
with a great big tape recorder on their
shoulder back 50 years ago
but
so with the advent of mini disc players
and then the mp3 player so all of a
sudden the sound is tremendously
portable can be found everywhere
online dictionaries text that's digital
so all of those things come together to
create sort of the perfect storm for
language learning
so and and so with that i started the
first language that i went after was
cantonese
uh and uh and through that uh you know
we i just we heard i heard on cantonese
radio here that there was a chinese
immigrant who got all his money stolen
at the airport and you know he came to
canada as an immigrant had all his life
savings stolen like he kept
ten thousand dollars in a black bag on
his
luggage uh cart you know which isn't
brilliant
and um so we said we'll give him a job
if he's good that's fine he stays if
he's no good then at least we helped him
out for a couple of months so he stayed
with us for eight months he had all
kinds of trouble communicating
he he just didn't understand like he
didn't culturally understand so we
started developing basically content i
would be interviewing members of the
rotary club who and these are business
people like a travel bureau or a doctor
or whatever electrician or whatever it
might be
here's these people here's these
canadians speaking in english about how
they live
and the thought was if this guy could
learn the words and expressions and also
become familiar with how people live
that would make it easier for him to
connect so that he could be a
better you know a more successful
immigrant to canada he ended up going
back to china
and that we tried to interest the
canadian government in that as a program
for immigrants because a lot of the
immigrants to canada are
sort of educated immigrants so these are
not illiterate peasants these are people
with a high level of education in their
own language
and
we thought they there was a role for
link to help immigrants we discovered
that immigrant service organizations are
more interested in how they can extract
more funding from the government not so
interested in things that might help
immigrants
so that didn't work out so then we said
okay we'll make it a multi-language
platform
without any clear business plan any idea
of what what this might lead to
it just the idea it would be fun to do
and that's basically the business model
for link it would be a fun thing to do
and a good thing to do people all over
the world and initially we had this
model where people recorded themselves
and transcribed it and put it up and
they earn points and stuff
which was had its
pros and cons it still happened i mean
still happens now we still do have that
model but uh and a lot of our content is
user generated but it's not typically
not recorded and transcribed it's it's
stuff that they've found
so the longer this went on the longer
this went on and we made every as i said
we made every possible mistake in terms
of the database we use in terms of the
everything we could have possibly done
wrong we did wrong
and but the more we got into it the more
we weren't going to give up
and so we stayed with it we stayed with
it we stayed with it and we're finally
at a point where we got our nose above
water here and but the determination was
that camel water were staying with it so
we're staying with it
and uh now things have come our way i
think the advent of uh mobile you know
like iphones and ipads for language
learning i mean people don't want to
just sit in front of their computer the
only the only way to study so that has
helped
a number of sort of technological
change has helped us
and uh so yeah that's that's your
explanation on the
language entrepreneurial side of the
business
and i should add
uh
because it's it's basically um you know
mark and i i shouldn't say we do it
together
mark does it
and does it in a practical way because
if we're up if it were up to me we'd
have
50 more useless functions on link we'd
have 100 languages
including uh i don't know
300 languages out of papua new guinea so
he keeps it on an even keel
uh tries to make it work as a business
and i interfere
i i
really the guru the face of link i'm the
fan spreading the word spreading the
word yeah there you have it and i think
all of this stuff as you say over time
more and more people look to the
internet look to youtube try to figure
out you know
there's obviously a move away even
before
uh coronavirus from from brick and
mortar and and doing things uh uh uh
more virtually uh so all of everything
just continues to work to move our way i
mean when we started out
you know trying to convince people to
pay on the internet was a was an
obstacle so so i mean it's just it's
second second nature now so it's
just over time we've
i think you hear that a lot in in when
people talk about businesses that half
the battle is persistence and staying
with it and and and being able to stay
with it um so yeah no it's uh anyway
it's
super um
rewarding especially when we have like
we have today with nick and patricio and
stuart uh
people who come on and users who come on
and and you know get it so well
uh not just
uh you know basically our approach
steve's approach to learning but also
you know how to how do you really use
the the the functionality that link
provides and uh yeah as i say very
rewarding and makes
makes it worthwhile i mean we we use it
we think it's great and to see other
people use it and think it's great um
yeah it's particularly rewarding because
it's not obvious like most people who
come to link don't understand how it
works don't understand why you learn
that way they're all conditioned all of
us have been conditioned at school to
learn a certain way and so it's very
rewarding for mark and and me to see all
of you come forward and not only you use
link in a creative way and the way we
would use link but you also go find
other resources to combine with link and
and i mean i love doing it like i love
learning these languages and and to see
other people doing the same thing is is
very rewarding
so
uh yeah i don't know with that i i don't
know you wanted to add one thing
okay i have this is a prototype mask
made by my wife
uh i think it's worthwhile spreading the
word
there's resistance everywhere
particularly in north america to wearing
a mask in those countries where they
wear masks not only in asia but also in
czech republic and so forth they have
been able to you know
see a big steep decline in their cases
so i just thought i'd put in a little pr
here get yourself a mask
make one buy one get one and wear it
because
apparently now and of course these
experts are constantly revising their
position on this but it seems it not
only prevents you from spreading it it
can prevent you from getting it and
every time you spread it or get it
you're putting more pressure on the
hospital system wherever you are so i
just wanted to throw that little bit of
propaganda in there well it seems like
like it's
every no government's had no problem
telling everybody to stay home
which is obviously much more impactful
uh
yeah wearing a mask is not that
impactful to everybody so if it
should help might help why i just don't
see the downside so yeah maybe we need
to make
link masks send them to everybody link
masks
[Music]
okay well thank you again thanks very
much patricia i don't know if you guys
want to have anything to add there at
the end
uh no just thanks for having me and
thanks for doing what you guys do
yeah no not at all thanks very much for
coming
uh i just want to add a personal
experience that i had
i started learning italian
on link
basically using only link youtube
and
podcast
and
i
i started for one year
and then i went to an italian school
and
i had spoken practically like
three hours of italian
in my whole life but i had read a lot
and listened
a lot
and uh they made me an exam and
i
achieved to be on the highest group
of the school
and i'm not saying this uh to talk well
about myself or whatever i'm saying this
because
it may feel like you may need to have
the
you feel like you need to speak to
uh
improve but if you're reading and
listening eventually speaking will be
much easier
and ironically the first question that
the teacher asked me when i entered the
classroom because i arrived late
she said
uh had you studied all the grammar
and i said like no
not at all
and yes i just wanted to share it how
how many years had the rest of the
students been studying italian for in
their school
probably uh
i don't know five years actually
it was the highest level the school was
c1
and uh so there were people who had i
don't know like
an italian mother
but lived in switzerland though and so
on
and
i
i felt uh a bit behind in writing but uh
in terms of communicating i
i could uh
be at the same level of the audience
other students
yeah
great
that's good great yeah great story um
okay well thanks again everybody for
joining us and um we'll sign off now but
look forward to our next gathering
take care
thank you for inviting me
okay bye bye